c'est l'heure de notre débat de société
dans ce sens public débat volontairement
décalée de l'actualité avec la dette de
la france au programme ce soir notre
pays emprunte un milliard d'euros par
jour depuis l'an dernier samia de chiens
comme les crise financière de 2008 celle
du co vite 19 à plonger les comptes de
l'état français dans le rouge en 2020 la
dette publique c'est à dire tous les
prêts que la france n'a pas encore
remboursé est passé à 115% du pib soit
une augmentation de près de 20 points en
un an un niveau resté stable depuis en
2022 le gouvernement prévoit une dette à
114 % du pib un chiffre qui pourrait
cependant être revu légèrement à la
baisse nous allons revoir nos hypothèses
pour que cette croissance en 2021 ne
soit pas à 6 mai à 6 heures il 25% alors
on peut se dire que passer de 6 à 6,25
savait pas beaucoup c'est énorme
économique cela a des conséquences sur
le niveau du déficit et sur le niveau de
la dette mais il n'y aura pas de miracle
le niveau de la dette restera élevé
cette année trop élevé pour jean
françois husson rapporteur général de la
commission des finances du sénat y avait
pas d'argent magique pour la dette il
n'y aura pas dardoise magique vous savez
ce qui faisait que ont secoué notre
ardoise et tout ça disparaît c'est et
donc il y aura un prix à payer
aujourd'hui l'exécutif le gouvernement
doit donner tous les éléments pour
montrer quel est l'effort quelques
pistes d'économies on imagine qu'elle
baisse de la dépense publique plan
d'urgence plan de relance plan
d'investissement pour soutenir
l'économie le gouvernement a fortement
augmenté les dépenses publiques près de
7 % en 2020 plus de 3% cette année la
gauche aussi s'inquiète du creusement de
la dette pour les générations futures
mais plutôt qu'une réduction des
dépenses elle suggère d'augmenter les
recettes s'il y a
beaucoup de nos concitoyens qui
souffrent de la crise il ya aussi un
certain nombre de secteurs qui on en
tirer des mines en profite et de grands
bénéfices et donc qu'on appelle à une
forme de contribution de solidarité ne
me paraîtrait pas du tout de mauvaise
politique d'après les prévisions du
gouvernement
le niveau de la dette publique devrait
rester au dessus des 115 % du pib au
moins jusqu'en 2026
la dette est ce qu'on va dans le mur est
ce qu'il faut forcément s'en inquiéter
on en débat agnès verdier-molinié
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes directrice
de la fondation ifrap think tank
indépendant qui évalue les politiques
publiques vous publiez la france
peut-elle tenir encore longtemps c'est
aux éditions albin michel et évidemment
la question de la dette est au coeur de
de cet ouvrage ya pas que ça mais c'est
vraiment une des questions importantes
mathieu plane bonsoir bienvenue vous
êtes économiste directeur adjoint du
département analyse et prévision de
l'ofce eu l'accueil également eric
delannoy bonsoir économise président du
cabinet de conseil tenzing et matthieu
croissandeau qui est toujours à mes
côtés
un peu d'histoire économique tient pour
commencer à la fin des années 70 la
dette représentait 21 % du produit
intérieur brut français regardez cette
courbe on est à 122 % et enfin c'est une
projection pour cette année 2021 quand
on voit ça on se dit on il faut
forcément être inquiet agnès verdier
verdier mon idée est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec cela faut-il forcément
sont inquiétés écoutez ça dépend d'où
vient cette dette
depuis les années 90 on s'est beaucoup
endetté on va bientôt vers les 3000
milliards de dette cette année là 2022
là on est en train de débattre du budget
un ici même au sénat aussi et ce budget
va nous emmener à 2950 milliards de
dette publique pour la france et ça
c'est seulement la dette au sens de
maastricht parce que aussi beaucoup de
dette hors bilan gens parlent
abondamment ya peu près 5 milliards de
dette hors bilan aussi d'engagement de
l'état qui sont pas comptés dans cette
dette alors on s'est endettée beaucoup
pour fonctionner et pas beaucoup pour
investir depuis les années 90 plus de
900 milliards de dettes pour fonctionner
- 2 700 milliards de dettes pour
investir donc le problème c'est que
finalement on creuse du déficit pour
payer des salaires des retraites de
l'assurance chômage et état et à la fin
c'est pas quelque chose de pérenne c'est
des milliards qui s'envole oui il faut
sortir de cette spirale si on s'était
endetté comme qualcomm comme l'allemagne
peu près pour investir
finalement on aurait juste investi on ne
se serait pas endetté autant pour
fonctionner lorsque même niveau
d'endettement que là que les allemands
donc aujourd'hui le problème aussi c'est
la divergence et le décrochage de la
france par rapport à l'allemagne 115%
dette pour la france quand les allemands
vont être à 75% dette par rapport à leur
richesse nationale ça c'est inquiétant
parce que on est dans une zone monétaire
on a un couple franco-allemand est
finalement au début des années 2000 on
était à peu près au même niveau et
maintenant on a complètement diverger
voilà c'est toutes ces questions là mais
il ya plein d'autres questions sous
jacentes mais l'avenir évidemment non
dans le débat mathieu plane votre
analyse est même question sur voilà
l'inquiétude face à ces face à ces
chiffres alors l'inquiétude on peut on
peut légitimement la voie après ce que
ça apporte des solutions n'en suis pas
sûr à faire c'est de comprendre ce qui
se passait il ya effectivement une forte
hausse de la dette publique comme on
peut le voir
il ya eu deux crises majeures 2007 2020
faut pas oublier forte hausse de la
dette publique ces fameux quoi qu'il en
coûte 1 c'est la façon de préserver
l'économie éviter les faillites le
cheval qu'on te parle de sacrifice des
générations futures leur sacrifice et si
allah chômage de masse et que les jeunes
trouvaient pas du travail il se trouve
que justement la croissance est plutôt
dynamique qu'on a des créations
d'emplois donc c'est ce qui a été fait
en france mais partout dans le monde ça
c'est le premier point ça c'est sur la
dernière période l'autre point qui est
assez paradoxal c'est que cette dette
est très élevé c'est vrai depuis 70 ans
n'a même jamais il a ça remonte à 40 ans
mais depuis soixante dix ans d'âge et
une telle dette mais on n'a jamais ou si
peu de charges d'intérêts c'est un peu
le grand paradoxe aujourd'hui du coût de
l'endettement si vous reprenez la même
chose aux graphiques ou le fait depuis
la fin des années 70 on paie aujourd'hui
1% du pib en charge d'intérêt donc ce
qu'on va rembourser réellement c'est
l'équivalent de ce qu'on paye et au
début des années 80 quand on avait 20
points de des publics donc les taux
d'intérêt la politique monétaire sont
fondamentales pour créer une
soutenabilité des depuis que ça veut pas
dire qu'il faudra pas faire d'effort
budgétairement qu'il faut pas donner la
priorité à l'investissement mais là qui
sont la soutenabilité notamment des
dettes publiques elles se posent aussi
vis-à-vis des créanciers parce que la
charge d'intérêts au président que les
conditions restent favorables dans le
monde macro économique a changé en fait
surtout plein de choses c'est que les
politiques monétaires ont des rôles qui
sont très différents de ce qu'on avait
il ya vingt à trente ans et deuxièmement
on a une épargne mondiale qui est
extrêmement abondante ce qui fait qu'on
a des antennes et taux d'intérêt très
bas et qui a une demande très forte pour
les actifs dits sûrs et paradoxalement
même avec une dette très élevée vous
êtes un actif sûr effectivement ça peut
poser question mais la question de dire
il faut revenir au monde d'avant et à
60% des public n'aurait pas beaucoup de
sens en tout cas actuellement et eric
delannoy
la france prévoyait d'émettre 260
milliards d'euros de dettes publiques à
moyen et long terme la en 2022 et
effectivement si je reprend l'argument
de mathieu plane on trouve beaucoup de
monde pour nous prêter c'est ça oui on
trouve beaucoup de monde d'abord pour
plein de raisons la première c'est que
d'abord tout le monde tout le monde sent
d'être il peut donc s'endetter n'est pas
un mal aujourd'hui la deuxième raison
c'est que la france mine de rien par
rapport à cette date qui est colossal à
un ensemble d'actifs très importants
actifs en termes d'actifs publics at-il
d'infrastructures qui donne confiance
dans la capacité de pouvoir un jour là
pouvoir la valoriser typiquement quand
les pays d'amérique latine se sont
endettés dans les années 80 on n'avait
pas en face ses actifs le seul actif qui
avait été actif de matières premières et
on savait qu'ils avaient des
problématiques par ailleurs de
corruption qui empêchait les valoriser
donc les actifs sont très importants
dans les sociétés pour pouvoir se dire
est ce que la signature est bonne ou
n'est pas neutre enfin on est sûr mine
de rien c'est ce qui est votre ski
mathieu quand on s'endette aujourd'hui
on diminue la charge d'intérêt parce que
dans la dette il y à la fois une
nouvelle dette faire face au déficit
public mais aussi ce qu'on appelle le
roll-over de la dette donc le fait on
s'endette pour rembourser une dette
précédente qui en général était beaucoup
plus cher et qu'à ce titre là en
empruntant 260 milliards on continue
aujourd'hui dans les conditions
d'endettement à faire baisser la charge
de la charge globale de la dette ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut le faire de
manière absolue moi je parlerais pas
d'inquiétude je parlais de vigilance
parce qu'on l'a vu il ya plein de
conditions qui font que que
l'endettement aujourd'hui il est
soutenable maintenant c'est pas des
conditions absolue et ça nécessite une
vigilance unis gyan sow niveau
macroéconomique et notamment une vision
ce niveau européen on peut en parler
tout à l'eau et on en parlera évidemment
mais est ce qu'il ya un enjeu de
souveraineté nationale derrière cette
cette dette
la question était jeune prêtre a été
beaucoup évoqué pendant toute la crise
je parle de cette dernière crise la
pandémie ont finalement la bce la banque
centrale européenne par le truchement de
la banque de france et enfin cédé rachat
de bêtes enfants par entrer dans tous
les détails mais finalement la banque
centrale européenne a racheté beaucoup
de dette publique pour la france est à
peu près la moitié des émissions à peu
près de 100 milliards sur les 400
milliards d'émissions parce que quand il
parle quand vous parlez de 260 milliards
de besoins de financement à moyen long
terme là vous parlez de l'état ne
parlait pas de la totalité des
administrations publiques a pas que
l'état qui scinde est un il ya aussi la
sécu il ya aussi
toute une ribambelle de strates qui
s'endettent aussi et puis comme ça a été
dit il faut rouler la dette l'ancien
dette donc qu'on dit qu'on rembourse pas
la dette mais en fait on est obligé
quand même quand ça arrive à échéance si
vous avez emprunté pour quatre ans pour
dix ans au bout de dix ans vous êtes
obligés de réemprunter pour financer la
vieille dette et cette vieille dette
elle pèse donc la bce certaine nous a
soulagés de des émissions qui était lié
à la crise duco vide mais il y avait
aussi toutes ces vieilles dettes qui
faillirent oui donc là on
on trouve des investisseurs sur le
marché pour nous acheter cette dette et
cela on sait pas trop qui sont parce que
il ya il n'y a pas tant que ça le
résident qui détiennent des résidents
français qui détiennent la dette
française c'est à peu près 50% qui est
détenue par des résidents et 50% par des
non résidents mais si vous enlevez la
part détenue par la bce bah là vous êtes
plutôt à 65% ans et les chiffres
d'olivier dussopt donc ça veut dire que
c'est 65 % de non résidents français qui
détiennent la dette or baissé que ça et
là mais moi quand je me suis penché pour
mon livre sur le sujet de qui détient la
tête français là ça devient hyper fort
parce que on sait pas trop on sait qu'il
ya des banques centrales alors ça c'est
sûr il ya beaucoup de banques centrales
qui est celle de la dette pour avoir
finalement des réserves en devises mais
là moi on me disait c'est beaucoup la
chine alors oui mais combien ah bon
c'est pas alors il ya beaucoup de nos
téléspectateurs qui découvrent qu'ils
découvrent ça ça non moi je suis pas un
économiste je réagis vraiment citoyens
électeurs je me dis ça nous affaiblit
potentiellement alors sur place nous
affaiblit s'offre aux tensions
s'affaiblir en principe allemande était
en euros 1 c'est quand même important
cirque une dette extérieure ça peut être
les allemands ça peut être aussi les
italiens et donc c'est aussi dans la
même monnaie le risque il est sur la
dette extérieure notamment les crises de
dettes elle passe aussi par des crises
de change et notamment parce qu'ils
avaient des endettements vis-à-vis des
pays stables et que la monnaie n'était
pas soutenable oui mais enfin là il est
un peu l'épouvantail chinois huayi les
pouvoirs des chinois c'est à dire d'un
coup les choix dirait j'arrête
d'investir en france je retire et les
choix ça représente pas beaucoup en
salle à
ses estimations soit moins de 10% ces
moines du bon sens et les estimations je
n'en sais absolument rien aujourd'hui on
nous rassure nous disons c'est 50% de la
dette n'est négociable qui est détenue
par des banques centrales le jour à
savoir mais en fait c'est pas si simple
que ça mais aller mal pour aller au bout
du raisonnement c'est ce qui est
intéressant là dessus c'est
effectivement ça posera un problème si
vous étiez vraiment
dans la ligne de mire des marchés avec
une banque centrale qui ne joue pas à
son rôle de prêteur en dernier ressort
effectivement il y posera une défiance
des investisseurs vis-à-vis de la dette
française il se trouve que dans un monde
d'instabilité en réalité où les tous les
pistes sont beaucoup endettées la france
est aujourd'hui malgré ce que dit agnès
il ya des choses effectivement sur
lesquels on peut se poser des questions
sur le déficit structurel du juste comme
ça est plutôt vu comme une valeur refuge
c'est à dire que l'allemagne ne peut pas
capter l'ensemble de l'épargné mondiale
l'allemagne c'est à peu près la
référence absolue sauf que avec les
états unis avec le plan by donne après
trump etc sont énormément d'été le
royaume uni c'est le brésil et l'italie
très endettée et l'espagne aussi certain
nombre de preuves donc la france fait
preuve d'une certaine stabilité et puis
sa dette comme ça a été dit hier une
contrepartie c'est qu'il ya quand même
pas mal d'actifs il ya aussi une épargne
nationale qui est importante on est
enrichi allez-y rapidement faire ses
sujets
paris très très très important on
connaît pas aujourd'hui les nationalités
qui détiennent à des français ça c'est
sûr il faudrait une information pas
forcément sur les identités mais où se
loge dans quel pays la dette française
on entre en studio elle s'est
demandé ce qu'on demandait d'ailleurs
les parlementaires qui ont demandé des
informations à bercy sur ce sujet à la
fois l'assemblée au sénat et ce pour
l'instant ils n'ont pas encore de
réponse j'espère qu'à roman ils auront
des réponses sur le trésor américain
donne beaucoup plus d'informations sur
où sont les détenteurs de la dette en
terme géographique par rapport à ce que
nous nous avons qui est vraiment très
très faible en information et est
vraiment le sujet c'est aussi de se dire
que c'est beaucoup des non-résidents en
france beaucoup plus des non-résidents
en france que dans les autres pays les
états unis ils sont très endettés mais
via que 30 % de la dette américaine qui
est détenue à l'étranger les italiens
sont très endettées n'y a que trop quels
sont les risques de la voiture en
question la souveraineté et puis après
on va parler un peu plus de politique
parce qu'il ya aussi un enjeu politique
autour de la question des souverainetés
pour moi aujourd'hui n'est pas un sujet
parce qu'effectivement si on devait
faire le diagramme de kiki problème
prend la dette on s'apercevrait que
finalement la dette elle est détenue par
l'europe parlera pour beaucoup un peu
par les états unis très peu parlé de
part en part par la chine et pourquoi
c'est difficile d'avoir cette
information est pourquoi ces mêmes
dynamiques et compliqué c'est pas
simplement parce que quand tu as chez
une banque achète de la dette elle
achète certes pour avoir des réserves
notamment quand c'est les non résidents
mais la suite aussi pour les instruments
de couverture couverture c'est
d'ailleurs ce couvert pour des contres
des problématiques de change donc elle
va mettre en face des pratiques de
change des delà de la de la monnaie
qu'elle aura qu'elle aura emprunté ça
veut dire que sur des avec des
instruments de couverture l'argent
bougez bougez énormément et donc il est
très difficile d'avoir une photo la date
de ce qui se passe et c'est très
volatile de fait
allez je reprends la main pour parler un
peu de politique et mathieu est ce que
pour vous c'est un thème de campagne
la dette en tout cas c'est pas un bon
thème de
pâques ce n'est pas un sujet mais
important et on est d'ailleurs là pour
en parler sa technique mais on se fait
pas élire en faisant de la dette l'axé
central de sa campagne quelques-uns s'y
sont essayés un françois bayrou qui
répétait la dette la dette comme le
montra ça va jamais fait gagner françois
fillon s'y essayer dernière fois leur
mise a perdu pour d'autres raisons mais
il avait commencé à décrocher avec un
programme de finances publiques qui
était quand même d'une orthodoxie quasi
punitive est en fait c'est assez
compréhensible parce que c'est pas
d'abord ce n'est pas une préoccupation
majeure des français est d'instituer la
par exemple a demandé il ya quinze jours
aux français quelle était leur laura les
priorités et qu'il est pour eux pour qu
est ce qu il est comment faudrait-il
leur choix pour la présidentielle et en
gros la dette arrivent en 13e position
dans les thèmes très loin très loin
derrière les premiers qui sont de
pouvoir d'achat la sécurité la santé
c'est pas c'est pas non plus à normal
parce que ce sont des mécanismes très
compliqués sont des sommes qui dépassent
l'entendement et puis tout ça paraît
loin parce que on dit oui on va
rembourser mais voilà on n'a pas
l'impression que ça va venir tout de
suite donc donc donc ça c'est la
deuxième raison et puis enfin dans une
campagne c'est même plutôt le temps des
dépenses que le temps des économies on
fait plutôt campagne que sur sur des
dépenses la dette en fait la question de
la dette à l'intérieur souvent en
deuxième rideau à partir du moment où
commencent à s'intéresser au chiffrage
est programmé commando candidats bon
c'est bien gentil mais comment vous
allez financer tout ça mais je disais
jusqu'à présent ça a fonctionné comme ça
cette année il ya quand même une petite
exception c'est qui est arrivé dans le
débat public le thème de la dette après
la crise qu vide et notamment celui de
la dette co-lead après la proposition
d'économistes de de l'annuler et c'est
comme ça d'abord que c'est venu dans la
ligne de la politesse cas des candidats
à la présence et on va faire un peu la
liste qui proposait seulement de l'admin
et cette dette devient mariage jean luc
mélenchon qui lui en tout cas considère
que la dette a atteint un niveau
irremboursable dit-il il a calculé ce
sont ces calculs selon lui s'il ya un
1.8 croissance par an il faudrait deux
cent quarante ans selon lui pour
l'honorer et il propose en tout cas
d'annuler la part de la dette française
qui est détenue par la banque centrale
européenne pour commencer arnaud
montebourg lui il plaide pour une
annulation concertée de tous les états
deux des membres de la zone euro pour
annuler la dette coheed pour le reste
des autres candidats de gauche sont
assez discrets le patron du ps olivier
faure lui propositions sur une taxe sur
les profiteurs de la crise les gars
femmes la grande distribution le big
pharma anne hidalgo peut-être cadeaux
problèmes de dette dans sa ville de
paris en tout cas n'a rien dit sur le
sujet de dette nationale
quant à yannick jadot lui il estimait au
printemps qui à partir du moment et on
en a parlé où on reconnaissait des taux
d'intérêt négatifs c'était pas un
problème pour le moment et les autres
conversations tournent vers l'exécutif à
l'exécutif évidemment il est pas
question d'annuler la dette que vida
bruno le maire l'a répété du côté de la
droite pas question non plus on parle
pas beaucoup de finances publiques sinon
pour taper sur le bilan de ma de macron
au milieu on peut vite que eux aussi
quand il était au pouvoir ont connu une
crise et que notamment sous sarkozy la
dette a explosé et puis enfin marine le
pen et ça c'est pas c'est pas
inintéressant elle s'est saisie de cette
question ouais c'est une crédibilité
économique qui lui faisait cruellement
défaut en 2010 est donc l acdi faire
plus orthodoxes que moi tu meurs et donc
elle a décidé de prôner le remboursement
de la dette en dix ans encore vous
expliquez à vos créanciers vous n'allez
pas les rembourser c'est assez difficile
d'aller leur redemander éventuellement
un prêt par derrière elle sait de quoi
elle parle pour le coup puisqu'on
rappelle qu'elle est quand même à la
tête d'un parti très très endettés
calmaient mais aussi edouard philippe
qui a fait une grosse alerte sur la
dette
c'était le jour de la création ministre
le jour de la création de son parti je
jouerai la loire l'us open quand on y va
écoutons edouard philippe l'ordre dans
la rue l'ordre dans les comptes ça me
paraît le premier défi et ça me parait
des défis cruciaux mais c'est c'est
court mais c'est clair la une du
challenge était quand même très très
forte et c'était vraiment l'alertent sur
les ponts de public l'alertent sur la
dette certes mathieu plane a très bien
souligné qu on a une charge de la dette
qui est très faible aujourd'hui autour
de 36 milliards ce qui est extrêmement
faible néanmoins tout ça est très
artificielle c'est parce que la banque
centrale rachète massivement encore des
dettes publiques qui ont fait baisser
aussi les taux et il faut se souvenir de
mars 2020 où tout d'un coup il y avait
des écarts de taux entre la france et
l'allemagne 2020 les allez rire oui mais
à ce moment là à ce moment là qu'a fait
la banque centrale est là elle a gonflé
les rachats de manière massive de public
pour éviter pour éviter que les baies
augmente mais donc enfin les taux que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui sont des
taux artificiellement bas et la salle
agences au total
et on sait très bien que si on était à 3
ou 4 % ça a été calculée 1 4% de taux
sur la dette française c'est attendait
dr oui mais on vous croyez vraiment que
les taux vont rester aussi bas
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une décision qu'il
faut personnes autour de cette table
n'en sais rien donc se préparer c'est se
préparer pour la prochaine crise en 2028
quoi ici on est à des taux parce que
tient il ya
80 milliards d'animaux on était on était
cinq
jeunes hommes des kings chiffres que
tout le monde peut comprendre belge
reprend la main une seconde taux
d'emprunt pour l'état disant on a
comparé parce qu'il faut effectivement
avoir un peu de mémoire 1980 était à 16
pour cent pour cent en 2010 5 % et
aujourd'hui on est à 0 oui donc vous
dites attention on peut aimer ça va
remonter
je suis pressé sur ce sujet sur une
fleur 2023 on à 180 milliards de dh
deuxième qui arrive à échéance de la
musique m'a fâché pas d'accord pour
plein de raisons la première raison
c'est que exactement comme il a commencé
à l'évoquer mathieu c'est qu'avant qu'on
ait une dette globale à 4% il faudrait
qu'on puisse avoir roulé la dette de
manière à ce que la dette qui était très
faible où on a même des dettes négative
puis s'attaque à 2% donc déjà donc cédé
à la détention sachant très mature
ce qu'on appelle les maturités il faut
voir que la france aujourd'hui 100 days
sur de plus en plus long terme c'est
qu'aujourd'hui que quasiment la moitié
de la dette et au delà de 10 ans alors
qu'avant on était sur des maturités aux
eaux autour de 5 ans donc ça veut dire
que pour avoir une dette à 4% déjà il
ferait tout au moins tabler sur 10 15
ans ont là dessus en personne ne peut
prédire ce que seront les et les taux à
10 15 ans premiers éléments deuxième
élément il ya un enjeu au niveau de la
banque centrale européenne la banque
centrale est un formidable amortisseur
de crise de dette pourquoi parce que
d'abord elle a son propre système
d'endettement deuxièmement c'est une
banque centrale qui fonctionne pas comme
une banque et donc l'idée qui consiste à
dire que la banque centrale peut pas
faire n'importe quoi c'est didier
orthodoxe qui a été battue en brèche par
les taux négatifs dans tout le monde
pensait que ce n'était pas possible
d'accord c'est à dire combien de temps d
un parent dont les taux négatifs ça fait
combien de temps que ça fait deux ans à
peu près qu'on est sur des taux négatifs
c'était 2019 avait à peu près et donc en
fait pour ne pas être technique on a
remplacé avec une politique monétaire
qui n'avait plus de marge de manoeuvre
puisque tous sont à zéro en négatif par
une politique de gestion bilancielle de
la dette avec le rachat des actifs et ça
on se rend compte que la banque centrale
en ayant pour la possibilité de racheter
ça permet d'amortir les problèmes ça
veut dire que les taux d'intérêt ont les
pilotes si jamais il ya un problème de
taux d'intérêt ont fait en sorte que la
banque centrale qui s'engage auprès des
pays européens puissent faire en sorte
de conserver des taux bas le problème
qui se pose c'est un consensus entre les
différentes banques centrales et
qu'effectivement entre les pays du nord
qui sont moins endettés que les pays du
sud il peut y avoir un 10 ans us qui
provoque une crise au mi6 un suspect
arrivé
je voudrais vous poser une question
finalement assez politique est ce que le
la tonalité générale de cette campagne
que ce soit l'action du président de la
république depuis plusieurs semaines ou
plusieurs mois on a un peu l'impression
dans là c'était le le plan relance 2030
mais il ya eu beaucoup d'annoncés
beaucoup d'argent et d'annoncer coup de
billard à chaque fois est ce que vous
croyez aussi que dans les dents les
promesses de campagne qui sont faites
parler des différents candidats il ya
cette idée d'un argent magique ou d'une
campagne de l'argent magique est ce que
vous ça vous inquiète sur il ya plein
d'éléments sur la crédibilité de la
parole publique sur ce que ça va
donner peut-être comme climat social
dans les années à venir comment vous
percevez le voilà cette ce climat de
campagne autour des promesses et autour
de l'argent magique comme ça a été dit
un la dette est pas une priorité
aujourd'hui c'est veut pas dire ça ne
sera pas ça c est clair qu' il ya
finalement on voit les programmes
économiques sont très peu bouclé c'est à
dire on a des informations très partiel
on voit pas on a donné mesure des
annonces de baisses d'impôts ou de
dépenses supplémentaires dont on voit
jamais les financements en face après on
est dans un moment très particulier a
effectivement crise kovy d'injection
énormément massive le quoi qu'il en
coûte ses 200 milliards
effectivement le gouvernement on a aussi
un peu profité pour faire des dépenses
pérennes la vraie question qui va se
poser à mon avis et 2023 c'est
aujourd'hui les règles budgétaires ont
été gelés en temps de crise mais elles
vont revenir à un moment donné peut-être
sous une nouvelle forme et c'est le
verrou de vous savez le pacte de
stabilité les critères maastricht qui
ont évolué dans le temps mais la grande
question c'est quelles sont les
nouvelles règles d'après crise ça veut
dire qu'effectivement il ya un certain
nombre de déficit qu'on appelle
structurelles qui seront pas durables
cirque en vous baisser durablement des
impôts sur la production liesse la taxe
d'habitation amanda il faut aussi des
financements en face là aujourd'hui on
est dans une période très particulière
où la priorité est donnée à la
croissance à l'investissement ce qui est
très bien mais avant il y aura un
atterrissage quand même donc je veux
dire c'est pas la priorité du moment les
candidats l'ont bien compris mais il
peut marquer même des forces de rappel
gérer à partir de 2023 et notamment
elles viendront pas des marchés mais
bien des questions européennes et
justement du consensus je nous vois
trouver sur ses réglages et avec les
partenaires opéraient sur le climat
social agnès verdier-molinié un
gouvernement un gouvernement qui dit non
après des manifestations de
revendications alors qu'on est sortis
d'une période d'un seul coup on a trouvé
de l'argent massivement alors certes
mais jc par la crise sanitaire qu'est ce
que ça peut donner dans les prochaines
heures mais je trouve que les additions
qui ont été faites sont des additions
ont gonflé quand on a souvent parlé des
450 milliards qui avait été mis sur la
table c'est faux en fait il ya 160
milliards de pge de prêts garantis par
l'état pour les entreprises mais c'est
pas cadeau ça va être remboursée donc on
fait des additions qui fausse
complètement le jugement du citoyen et
ça c'est extrêmement mauvais par
ailleurs vous dites est ce qu'il ya des
propositions d'argent magique de de
dépenses très importantes des différents
candidats nous évidemment la fondation
ifrap qu'on est en train de commencer à
chiffrer tout ça et ça c'est marrant
d'ailleurs mais pour l'instant on n'a
pas encore publié et puis il ya encore
des choses à affiner sur les
propositions c'est encore assez floues
les programmes rifle ou les programmes
sont pas à sont pas très documenté donc
on va s'abstenir de publier pour
l'instant mais il ya des choses assez
rigolote néanmoins je regarde beaucoup
ce que fait le gouvernement aussi parce
que celui qui utilise l'argent magique
le plus en ce moment c'est quand même le
gouvernement et mathieu a eu totalement
raison de le souligner il ya beaucoup de
choses de dépenses supplémentaires dans
le budget 2022 qui commence à être
discutés sur lesquels finalement il n'y
a pas d'information donc on a eu pour la
première fois moi j'ai jamais vu ça
depuis toutes ces années où on travaille
sur ces questions on a une loi de
finances mais on nous dit ira 5
milliards de dépenses supplémentaires
mais le mois arrivé au fil de l'eau quoi
pour avec le pour le projet le grand
plan d'investissement qui va représenter
les trois ou quatre milliards outre le
fait qu'on recycle énormément des
crédits qui était déjà dans le passé
il y en a 20 milliards qui sont déjà
budgétés bon bref mais ça c'est encore
une autre chose ce que je vois c'est que
la croissance 2021 elle est hyper boosté
à l'hélium de la dépense publique et ça
c'est inquiétant et beaucoup plus qu'en
allemagne c'est à dire qu'un tiers des 6
% de croissance que nous avons c'est à
dire plus de points de croissance
viennent de l'augmentation de la dépense
et ça ça c'est vraiment un sujet qui à
mon avis ils méritent d'être mis sur la
table ou et crée la valeur ajoutée est
ce que c'est de la vraie valeur ajoutée
est ce que c'est de la croissance qui en
fait sur gonflés et payée sur du déficit
qu'on va léguer aux générations d'après
non mais ça sympa
on l'a bien compris et comme je vois qu
eric delannoy est pas tout à fait
d'accord je donne la vraie ruche
je suis d'accord avec agnès c'est que
c'est de dire qu'en fait enfin la dette
ce qui est important c'est savoir c'est
pourquoi on s'endette et effectivement
il ya eu d incurie et ce qui risque de
se passer dans la campagne
présidentielle c'est que comme il ya eu
l'argent magie ton guy que ça va
continuer et que donc les eaux et les
programmes vont être en surenchère de
réformes mais il le disait ma grand
c'est de dire c'est de l'investissement
il le dit à chaque fois jala c'est qu'il
abrège j'aime bien leur mission c'est
que on a on est on a isolé une dette qui
s'appelle la dette qu'ovide ce qui est
assez drôle d'ailleurs c'est que la
dette de la crise de 2007 2008 qui était
de l'ordre de 400 milliards on l'a
jamais isolé celle là on n'en a pas
parlé les rentrées en pot commun la
dette kovy dans les isoler pourquoi
parce que c'est quand même la première
fois qu'on prend le parti dans un
gouvernement de dire la dette doit
servir à quelque chose or là la dette
qu'ovide elle sert à éviter un
effondrement éviter un effondrement
c'est pas de la valeur créée c'est pas
de la valeur future celle là on pourra
pas à le rembourser quoi qu'on en dise
c'est trop important ça peut pas se
rembourser par l'inflation ça peut pas
se rembourser par les impôts ça peut pas
se redresser par la croissance c'est pas
vrai faudra trouver autre chose dont
vous dites la dette qu'ovide il faut
quoi l'annuler alors après il faut
réfléchir à comment on peut faire je
vais pas m'avancer sur ce terrain là
parce que après il ya des effets
d'annoncé qui sont délétères sous
quinzaine si vous annoncez vous pouvez
annuler une dette alors là c'est la
foire a du coup on peut s'endetter on
peut faire ce qu'on veut puisqu'on peut
l'annuler donc je pense qu'il ya un
tempo pour pouvoir annoncer des
solutions et ceux d'un pot de mon point
de vue n'est pas réunies donc c'est pas
le moment de sa d'actionner
éventuellement ce jugement d'un gie
nation de l'apprécier pas le moment
parce que ça donnerait des signaux
économiques qui sont extrêmement délai
de toute façon on peut pas le faire tous
alors non mais après tout c'est une
décision les vrais europe et avec ses
pieds puis en plus les délais
aujourd'hui les traders ne le permettent
pas néanmoins je vous ai terminé sur le
fait qu' il y a aujourd'hui de la dette
qu'on veut faire qui est qui correspond
aux plans de relance au plan européen
plan de relance français qu'il a
correspond à la valeur future parce que
quand on dit qu'on va réhabiliter des
centrales nucléaires quand on dit qu'on
va aimer améliorer le système de santé
sur les structures et non pas sur le
financement les dépenses de santé quand
on dit qu'on va améliorer qu'on va finir
qu'on va financer la transition
écologique ont fait de l'investissement
et la création de leur futur donc
l'endettement moi me pose pas de
problème à partir du moment où il est
pas cher ce qui est le cas et où il est
affecté et aujourd'hui on crée de plus
en plus d'outils d'affectation de de la
dette donc de ce point de vue là sa part
est de mon point de vue être une saine
gestion qui mérite d'être continuer et
la part des deals nourith qui est
consacré à l'investissement
non mais enfin où jamais aller vers ça
dépend le problème
sur la notion d'investissement s'est
séparé mémoire et demain de même si on
me fait une fut si on me met 10
milliards sur la table pour dire il faut
mieux payer les profs et réformer les
pédagogies et fait en sorte d'améliorer
la formation tout on agit je prendrai ça
pour un investissement classiquement
dans le pib on pense à pour une dépense
sauf que vous et ça c'est dramatique que
vous êtes n'avait pas gratter que la
dépense par rapport au pib entre la
france et l'allemagne en éducation on
est au même niveau mais sache que
l'allemagne l'allemagne dont l'allemagne
sauf que sauf qu'on a on les problèmes
qu'on as l'allemagne un problème
d'infrastructures majeures l'allemagne
des travailleurs sur la barre en tant
que contribuable en tant qu'etat payeur
peu près autant qu'en rencontre les
pensions et les rémunérations messi mais
l'affront semblait les des pandas font
se trouvent par budget mission parmi
vous regardez quand on rentre vraiment à
l'intérieur des chemins il se rend
compte que le problème c'est leur
problème d'allocation de moyens ce n'est
pas un problème d'augmenter les moyens
record mais une fois qu'on a dit ça on
n'a rien volé anglicismes et c'est un
problème de ce parce que en france vous
dites est un professeur je vous embauche
à vie vous aurez une très bonne retraite
ne serait pas très bien payé pendant
votre carrière en allemagne c'est
différent on dit finalement je vous
embauche vous aurez beaucoup plus
d'heures passées à l'école vous il y
aura moins de surveillants vous vous
aurez des obligations de rencontrer les
parents toutes les semaines et c'est
tout ce qui se passe en allemagne
concrètement est très différent de ce
qui se passe en france il ya moins de
personnel de fonctions support il ya
moins de surveillants il ya plus
d'heures passées et il ya finalement des
pensions je voudrais revenir sur la
dette qu'ovide et qu'est ce qu'on fait
de la dette qu idy nous reste à peu près
à moins de dix minutes heure et huit
minutes et je vous écoute et thomas
piketty c'était au mois de février
dernier avec une centaine d'autres
économies s'ils publient une tribune en
faveur de l'annulation des deux communes
détenues par la bce ait coûté le set sur
france inter la banque centrale
européenne elle même détient maintenant
une très grande partie des dettes
publiques de la zone euro c'est environ
20 % au début de l'année 2020 et là on
s'approche de 30% parce qu'en fait
pendant l'année 2020 c'est la banque
centrale européenne qui a financé plus
de 80% des émissions de dette fait par
les états européens qui ont permis
d'éviter un effondrement complet des
revenus des décès des européens de
l'économie à partir de là certains
disent bon de toute façon comme on ne va
pas la rembourser que c'est un taux
d'intérêt zéro ça sert à rien de
l'annuler on pourrait la laisser comme
ça sur le bilan de la gsee pendant 50
ans avec nous la position que défend est
un peu différente de dire écoutez
puisque si on est d'accord sur le fait
qu'on va jamais la rembourser il faudra
mieux officialisé la situation alors ça
va pas tout régler sire que de toute
façon moi je veux vraiment insister sur
le sur le fait que à la fin des fins il
faudra un prélèvement sur les plus
grandes fortunes privées pour vraiment
réduire l'endettement c'est on va pas
tout résoudre avec la bce thomas piketty
fait aussi de la politique avec la
solution killer
qu'il évoque on la remboursera jamais
cette dette qu'ovide est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça mathieu planeur
rembourser ça dépend quelle est la
trajectoire dette publique vous mettez
dans le temps des landes à écrire un
logiciel nous aller se perdre et watch
qui permet de faire des projections à
long terme selon les différents
paramètres dont je vais pas rentrer dans
le détail mais la question c'est la
trajectoire future de la dette c est ce
qu on reste durablement à 120 ou 115% du
pib ce qu'on revient à 100 est ce qu'on
se maintient voilà tout ça est important
sur l'annulation de la dette savoir
cette dette dénis banques centrales la
banque centrale elle appartient aux
états en réalité est que en fait c'est
la banque de france qui détient en
partie de cette dette et donc on verse
des intérêts pour notamment pour
rembourser mais qui sont reversés par la
banque centrale à l'état donc en fait
c'est nul c'est une opération nul donc
en fait il n'ya pas il n'y a pas
vraiment de problème le risque d'affoler
tout le monde en voulant annuler cette
dette annulée la dette n'aurait pas de
sens sachant que la bce est justement
indépendante même s'il appartient aux
états voulaient dire que l'europe
s'affaiblirait si elle décider
collectivement d'un duel avec kobe qui
ont fait défaut sur une dette cds pays
qui ne pouvaient pas rembourser dans des
situations financières qu'il faut le
faire sans le dire non impossible
sincère une bce est indépendante il
faudrait que tous les états soient
d'accord allez une fois de plus cette
date là peut être maintenue dans le
bilan des banques centrales de façon
extrêmement longue donc ça peut être
amorti sur plusieurs générations donc
étant donné que c'est ce qu'on appelle
un choc exogène c'est pas lié à une
mauvaise gestion des finances publiques
tout le monde a subi la crise qu vide dû
s'endetter pour sauver ses économies
donc on peut traiter cette dette de
façon différente mais l'annuler par
contre donnera un signal qui serait
extrêmement mauvais très attention dans
le bilan de la bce en fait de la banque
de france il ya 600 milliards de dette
française donc il ya beaucoup plus que
la dette kovy tricot sensu l'un des 300
donc là là en fait tout le monde dit
n'importe quoi sur ces sujets c'est à
dire que quand vous regardez j'espère
que grand mais quand même
vous regardez ce qui est dit c'est à
dire y'a qu'à annuler ce que je détiens
comme dette française d'abord il ya deux
fois plus de dette détenue par la bce
que d'être évident non mais sérieux le
réseau mais c'est quand même un sujet
ensuite mathieu a complètement raison de
dire qu'en fait c'est la banque de
france qui le détient à partir du moment
où si vous annulez en fait vous creusez
le bilan de la banque de france est
derrière vous deux est obligé de
refinancer et potentiellement jeu mis
ses capitaux et si si mais si mais non
non non je demande au nom de toute façon
ne sera censé pas une solution voilà
c'est pas une solution ça ça ne sera
jamais une solution
la bonne solution c'est mieux gérer nos
finances publiques mais en fumée mais si
mais si ses finances publiques
si je peux aider mes administrés de la
france sur nos finances publiques tous
les yeux faut pas confondre les shows
eric de la langue à son tour il faut pas
confondre deux choses la mieux gérer les
finances publiques oui évidemment on a
des fonctionnaires qui n'ont pas bien
employé
là on est social mais bon il ya aussi
des choses qui sont très bien nous
sommes le pays le plus redistributif en
france qui avons le meilleur système de
retraites après faut savoir si c'est
bien ou pas bien c'est un autre sujet
csn d'un mail mais les les les sommes ne
sont pas les mêmes d'abord piketty quand
il parle de deux d'aller capter la
richesse et les plus riches d'abord
c'est déjà ce qu'on fait je rappelle que
70 % du du revenu et f1 des impôts sont
payés par 10 % des contribuables même
pas donc donc c'est déjà fait c'est déjà
on est déjà très sûr fiscalisés et en
plus les montants en augmenter les
impôts on serait dans l'ordre de 15
milliards par an un peu plus ce qui n'a
aucune commune mesure avec ce qu'on doit
rembourser donc c'est pas la solution
c'est pas la solution donc oui il faut
améliorer la gestion dépenses publiques
mais le système de la bce c'est faux de
dire que ce n'est pas possible moi
autant je suis pas d'accord et piketty
sur sur les solutions apportées au temps
il faut imaginer des des solutions
hétérodoxes qui qui sont sur la dette
commis dans cette partie l'avoir fait en
sorte de la gérer la solution les
solutions hétérodoxes c'est quoi c'est
ferran sûr de regarder qui la détient
effectivement et puis on peut se poser
la question de savoir si dans les
paradis fiscaux il ya un clip qui la
détiennent ou pas ça ça pourrait être
aussi intéressant de regarder moi nul à
la dette sur des gens qui ne détiennent
les paradis fiscaux ça me pose aucun
problème on pourrait se poser la
question de savoir s' est d'être là
comme elle est détenue par la banque
centrale effectivement on peut faire une
gestion bilancielle différent de la
banque centrale et ce n'est pas vrai de
dire qu'on peut faire les refinancer
j'entends ça mais vous le savez tout à
l'heure et semir pardon je vais dire un
mot
le mot confiance je veux dire un mot le
mot confiance la confiance des créancier
de la manse vous vous dites attention à
la confiance et à qosi de la france ou
de l'europe d'ailleurs donc si on sait
pas si on adule c'est d'être comme hydro
on risque de perdre la crainte était une
forme de dette perpétuelle en réalité
fameux ce qu'on appelle rowling ce
qu'elle se renouvelle l'expérience et la
trajectoire de dettes qu'on veut sur les
cinquante prochaines années c'est pas la
même chose de dire on doit revenir à 60%
du pied de dette ou revenir à 100% sur
50 ans là on est installé pour cent mais
parce que ya pas de formule miracle je
veux dire même si on parle des retraites
imaginons qu'on fasse un gros choc sur
les retraites faudra bien que quelqu'un
paye au bout du au bout du compte donc
sur un effet sur la croissance ont un
effet sur les revenus s'est en effet sur
les profits et cette croissance la halle
a un effet sur la soutenabilité de la
dette donc c'est plein de paramètres là
des banques c'est extrêmement compliqué
et ça se gère dans le temps non l'erreur
c'est de penser qu'il va falloir réduire
très vite cette dette par exemple qui
crée un choc récessif sur l'économie
c'est l'erreur qui a été faite en 2011
2012 on a eu un choc d'austérité majeur
par l'impôt sur tout
petit et la chaussure les hanter les
imports on n'a pas baissé les dépenses
accord mais après ça c'est vous mais je
sais ce que voulait dire mais la version
wii s'est fortement les dépenses de
retraite je suis pas sûr que ça aura un
effet sur la croissance dans tous les
sports
la question c'est comment préserver la
croissance en fait la dette ont la
capacité de rendre sa dette c'est votre
pib donc le risque c'est de vouloir
réduire trop vite la dette c'est de
casser la croissance est de rendre
insoutenable justement lors mention de
la dette donc ce qui est important c'est
l'institut les institutions la confiance
dont vous parlez et notamment le rôle de
la banque centrale est d'avoir une
crédibilité sur le long terme dans
l'autre électro
crédibilité elle s'agrippe par les
réformes les rayons de stationner les
réformes de fond le message est passé
dernièrement
c'est plus un passionné la ville se
lâchent pas les al'avantage de la dette
copine c'est tout le monde a dû en
prendre un petit peu c'est à dire que
même l'allemagne a fait de la dette
qu'ovide et l'intérêt cette dette
qu'ovide c'est tout le monde en a eu et
donc il n'y a pas de problème de
crédibilité à faire en sorte que tout le
monde la baisse et c'est pour ça que ça
va passer par une un effet de conviction
niveau de l'aide de l'europe pour faire
en sorte de trouver un moyen commun de
pouvoir la gérer et ça c'est possible et
c'est inédit moi ce que je pense c'est
qu'il faudra sauver trouver des
solutions hétérodoxes pour gérer cette
dette comme il a été dit a inventé les
semis oui comme on a inventé les taux
négatifs impossible
merci à tous d'y avoir participé
agnès verdier-molinié je rappelle le
titre de votre livre la france peut-elle
tenir encore longtemps c'est publié aux
éditions albin michel
voilà merci à tous de votre fidélité
voilà on est content parce que vous êtes
de plus en plus nombreux à nous regarder
tous les soirs donc ça fait plaisir
matthieu croissandeau vous tenez la
boutique dommages au nom prénom mais ça
c'est du bonheur aux sais je sais que ça
va très bien se passer comme la dernière
fois donc ça je vous laisse l'équipe et
la boutique avec plaisir je trouve moi
lundi puisque je vais partir au congrès
national des sapeurs pompiers de france
pour m'occuper notamment des orphelins
des pompiers dont le suis je pars à
voilà ça fait partie aussi de mes
missions